Hi everyone it's Charlie this is going to be my Game of Thrones finale video for the top
10 questions that they have to
answer before the end of the series just
long running big question marks that
hopefully they'll pay off or at least
give us an idea that we can use as fans
to extrapolate on so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the Game of Thrones videos obviously
it's the finale of the main show but
I'll be doing Game of Thrones prequel
videos as we start to learn more about
that they're getting ready to start
filming right now there's been
conflicting evidence about what's going
on with that so of course I'll do
prequel videos next week after we get
done talking about the finale we'll do a
new round of the HBO now giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened on Game of
Thrones so far but starting with number
10 will they pay off Daenerys as visions
from the Iron Throne in the house of the
undying meaning that she never actually
gets to sit on the Iron Throne the
things that she's fought so hard for
this whole time reaching it winning
quote-unquote so to speak but never
actually getting to enjoy the fruits of
her victory bittersweet fruits of
victory if you look at all the damage
that she did to the red cape during
episode 5 she did not destroy the iron
throne room she just destroyed the
Lannister lion that had replaced the
seven pointed star that sat above the
Iron Throne which is a nice metaphor for
her kicking Cersei to the curb so to
speak or kicking her down to the
basement where she was then crushed by
the rest of the Red Keep has it caved in
number nine if Daenerys really does wind
up dying what will drogon do because
he's a weapon of mass destruction and he
would probably be pissed if Daenerys
died would he just live out the rest of
his life as a writer less dragon roaming
around the world where he pleases
dragons with proper access to a good
food source would just continue to grow
the older and older that they get that
was why balerion the black dread grew so
big is just because he lived to be so
old and he continued to grow he was
close to about 200 years old at the time
of death and drogon is less than 10
years old so just imagine
he could continue living for a couple
hundred more years there is precedence
for riderless dragons in A Song of Ice
and Fire after the doom of Valyria
because you have to imagine that during
that era the rise of the freehold there
were dragons everywhere all over the
place but after the doom most of the
dragons that survived were Targaryen
dragons there was a time during the
dance of the Dragons the Targaryen Civil
War that happened a long time before the
actual Blackfyre rebellion where there
were six riderless dragons living on
Dragonstone
so after Aegon's conquest it wasn't
unusual for there to be a lot of
riderless dragons just chilling around
number eight follow-up question to that
Daenerys question of course Jon Snow's
told us several times last season and
this season as recently as season eight
episode five that he absolutely does not
want to be king so if he's forced into a
situation where Daenerys isn't around
anymore and he's the last remaining true
Targaryen heir to the Iron Throne what
did the Lords of the realm do if he
refuses them again they've actually been
moments in Westeros see history where
matters of succession become a really
big problem in what has happened is is
the call a Great Council where all the
Lords of the different realms come
together to decide who's going to be the
next king it's the closest thing that
Westeros has ever had to a parliament
but they would only come together
briefly and it's only happened three
times in the last 300 years since
Aegon's conquest although there have
been many more failed attempts to call a
great council the most recent one was
when Catelyn Stark tried to convince
Renly that he Stannis and Robb Stark
should all hold a great council to deal
with the issue of Joffe Baratheon after
they discovered that he was the bastard
son of Jaime Lannister not Robert
Baratheon the very first grey council
was called after an event very similar
to what's playing out on the TV show
right now and season 8 with a succession
issue yeah but Jon Snow and Daenerys
that both have a claim to the Iron
Throne but technically the male heir has
a stronger claim the reason why Jon Snow
has the stronger claim to the Iron
Throne is because Westeros history has
typically practiced male favoring
primogeniture where the male heir of the
oldest living male heir inherits
everything before any of the kings other
children so even though Daenerys is the
only living child of the Mad King
technically the line of succession skips
her and goes straight to Jon Snow the
mad Kings grandson because Jon Snow
the oldest living legitimate male heir
of Rhaegar Targaryen who was the oldest
living legitimate male heir of the Mad
King in real life a really good example
that is Prince William he's a head of
the line of succession of his uncle's
Prince Andrew and Prince Phillip because
he's the oldest living male heir of
Prince Charles who's the oldest living
male heir of Queen Elizabeth during this
very first Great Council the reason why
it was called is because Jerris the
first and queen alicent had a succession
issue where Jo Harris the first skipped
over his oldest living granddaughter who
was technically the closest relation by
blood for a male cousin because he felt
like the realm would support a stronger
claim from the male even though his
granddaughter was technically the
closest relation to him by blood so it's
not unusual for Westeros to call a Great
Council to decide matters of State but
number 7 if Aria told Gendry that she
doesn't want to be a lady of a castle
what does she do after this does she
continue acting like a rogue assassin
dishing out justice or taking contracts
on the DL she's way too famous to
continue living in Westeros too many
people know her face even though she
can't wear other people's faces
there was a scene during season 6
episode 8 that I hope that they pay off
because it seemed like a pretty big
setup for a way to send her character
off at the end of the series she's
talking to lady crane talking about
escaping from the faceless people
leaving this life and she says where
will you go or he eventually says what's
west of Westeros says I'd like to see
that someday well when you go east
Westeros is West
but what's west of Westeros I don't know
nobody does that
so do they pay that off by having one of
her final shots on the series B of her
sailing beyond the sunset sea to the
Western continent otherwise her only
other option would be to go back to
Essos but just remember during the end
of season 4 beginning of season 5 where
you see arya boarding a ship to go away
will they do something similar like that
for her at the end of the game of
Thrones series will that be one of the
final shots of her just sailing off into
the unknown 6 tyrion took a weird
interest in bran stark after the battle
with the White Walkers and had this
whole big scene talking to him about
being
the only living male heir to Ned Stark
you would make a great Lord of
Winterfell
even though bran said I don't really
want anything anymore later in that very
same episode when Varys was talking to
Tyrion about possibly getting rid of
Daenerys he said maybe the best choice
for a king would be one that doesn't
want power
so if Jon Snow were to refuse the throne
who would become the next king if the
Lord's even want another King Gendry is
another newly minted heir with a now
legitimate claim to the Iron Throne
through Robert Baratheon but as history
repeats itself during a song of ice and
fire several times I think people would
be worried the Gendry would just be
another weak King like Robert Baratheon
there are a lot of people that are
wondering if they would make bran stark
the new king how would that even work
because his brand said he doesn't want
anything literally anything beyond
probably three regular meals and
handicap access to a nearby weirwood
tree for the most part he's basically a
glorified library of world history with
perfect recall so he's more useful in
situations where you need lots of
detailed information about things so you
need a situation where bran would have
someone around him to help focus his
attention and even if they just want to
make him a figurehead he'd really be
better off living with the arch maesters
in the Citadel with a team of them
around him just writing down every bit
of history they can get out of him
because of its the maesters job to
record history and bran is literal
history he can tell them everything
that's ever happened in the greatest
detail then why wouldn't you take
advantage of that and have the maesters
start recording everything five a lot of
us been wondering will there actually be
an Iron Throne anymore or will they as
we've all suspected just destroy it for
symbolic reasons you can't win the Iron
Throne if there's no Iron Throne anymore
when HBO started promoting Game of
Thrones Season 8 they used the for the
throne hashtag we were all like that
doesn't make any sense because we were
still thinking that the White Walkers
were going to be the biggest threat like
the Iron Throne isn't even going to matter
anymore by the end of the series because
we're dealing with the army of the Dead
it's life or death here who cares about
a pointy throne made up a bunch of
swords number four a lot of people
asking will brought ever get his bigger
castle and who's going to be the new
warden of Highgarden in the reach who's
going to be the new warden of the West
ruling from Casterly Rock it seems like
Tyrians days are numbered so if Tyrion
is around anymore then all the
Lannisters are gone who is going to take
Casterly Rock we can already probably
get that Sansa is going to continue to be
warden s of the north sweet Robyn would
continue to rule from the Vale Yara
Greyjoy will be the lady the Iron
Islands and whoever winds up being
picked to succeed Jon Snow if Jon Snow
abdicates the Iron Throne then that
person would be Lord of the Crown lands
if not King in name only if they decide
to adopt a policy more like modern-day
British government where the crown
wields no actual political power and is
therefore more symbolic and cultural
value a lot of people wondering if
they're going to adopt the democratic
theory of Westeros like is that going to
be the future of the kingdom going
forward three really important one that
we haven't talked about a whole lot will
the show's ending provide a clear thesis
for what a Song of Ice and Fire is
really about there's going to be a lot of
arguments for what Game of Thrones has
really been about this whole time it's
not about climate change I'll tell you
that people try to liken it to allegory
but recent events seem to suggest it's
more of a story about the dangers of
autocracy and putting so much power in
the hands of a single person the value
of shared rule people working towards
the common good all the while subverting
a lot of the tropes of typical fantasy
stories about good and evil there is no
true good there is no true evil only
bitter victories and the reality that
you're faced with going forward like
Martin talks a lot about the time that
happened after aragorn's victory after
he ascended the throne how did they deal
with all the orcs did he go around
ending all the orc babies after that so
no one really gets to ride off into the
sunset with a classic happily ever after
just very general broad themes that
everybody in 50 hundred hundred and
fifty years could read and apply to
their own lives not any kind of direct
allegory for what's happening in present
day for us George RR Martin said that
his ending was inspired a lot by
Tolkien's ending the Lord of the Rings
and talking absolutely hated the idea of
allegory in the suggestion that his
books were about World War 1 and World
War 2 he was very adamant that he wasn't
referenced anything in present day when
he was writing so the people at hundreds
of years could read Lord of the Rings
and apply general themes of what's
happening to whatever it's happening to
them in that future timeline number two
rather big question will Jon Snow ever
give ghost the good boy hugs and pats on
the head that he deserves like he just
kind of rode off into the sunset what
torment a lot of people are expecting
that we'll see ghosts again before the
end of the series then probably one of
the biggest questions number one
the ending give us a good sense as to
whether or not history will eventually
repeat itself again as and will they
ever be any more by Walker's the threat
of another long night in a thousand
years will bran also be able to pass his
abilities on to another three-eyed Raven
when he gets ready to die of old age
just like the Bloodraven past his
abilities to brand before he died
remember when bran said that he was the
literal living memory of all of
mankind's history obviously that has to
continue living so he would have to pass
his knowledge on to another three-eyed
Raven
but what'll happen is is my finale video
will post Sunday night just like normal
and then I'll do a bunch of bonus videos
after just reflecting on the series if
there's any specific videos you want me
to do let me know in the comments don't
forget about the bonus episode that's
airing the week after the finale I'll do
a video for that just like I would for
any of the other episode videos then
obviously I'll start doing some Game of
Thrones prequel videos but I don't think
that that's supposed to premiere till
next spring at the earliest maybe next
summer depending on how quickly they get
through their episode production
schedule this summer but don't forget we
have Watchmen coming this fall to HBO we
have The Witcher Netflix series we have
the Lord of the Rings series which is
probably going to start sometime towards
the end of next year there's a bunch of
other big stuff that's starting later
this year but as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you'll see the
videos when I post them so you'll see
that stuff no worries I'll leave the
giveaway open till I start posting bonus
videos on Monday so I'll just remind
people when I post my finale video
tomorrow click here for my Game of
Thrones season 8 episode 6 finale
trailer video and click here for my Game
of Thrones season 8 episode 5 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!